un autre des olympiques christiane
ayotte la championne de la lutte
antidopage
on est à sa 30e année à la tête du
laboratoire de contrôle du dopage
sportif malien rs à cette occasion
retraçons des moments marquants de sa
lutte épique contre le dopage dans le
sport
je n'ai jamais
toucher à des la paix ou de ma vie je
n'ai pas utilisé de produits dopants
pour gagner les deux tours de france
d'un élément du tour de france quand
bien d'abus on découvre maintenant
horrifié sur ces beaux athlètes loeb
d'opale chez daunat but
[Musique]
il avait rien sur le contrôle du dopage
au début des années 80 aucun contrôle
hors compétition quand tout à coup il ya
eu les jeux panaméricains un scandale
épouvantable dans ces années là
évidemment les parias c'était les
haltérophiles et on sait bien que
l'haltérophilie c'était une affaire des
pays de l'est beaucoup à l'époque ses
regrets sur ce soft gros morceau les
couleurs et notre gouvernement canadien
envoyer notre cohorte d'haltérophilie en
tchécoslovaquie pour des entraînements
pré olympique alors légaux nous disaient
qu'est ce que qu'est ce que vous pensez
qu'il se passe là il nous doper nous
apprennent à ce groupe est bien déjouer
les tests
et c'est vous dire comment le milieu
quand j'ai commencé c'était troublant
j'ai bien compris rapidement que le
pensait pour tricher ici il faisait ce
qu'on leur demandait de faire le dopage
les anabolisants ça c'était un briquet
dans le sport quand ça a été découvert
par la science pour d'autres fins que du
dopage mais ça a été importé là
et finalement lieu comme un concours à
la veille des olympiques de los angele
où le gouvernement voulait tester toute
la cohorte d'athlètes canadiens avant le
départ pour les jeux et moi j'aimais ma
méthode à l'épreuve cette fois là moi je
me souviens il était une heure du matin
et j'étais en train d'injecter part ça
se faisait à la main à l'époque et le
tout à coup j'ai eu mon premier résultat
positif mais dans ma tête c'est un
succès scientifiques et jeter l'eau il
ya ça marche je veux tout de suite voir
l'autre n'avaient rien détecté jeter la
victoire mais rapidement ça déboule et
j'ai vu le suivi qui était donné et j'ai
compris qu'il y avait un impact de ces
travaux scientifiques sur la vie de deux
haltérophiles je réalisais que j'étais
pour être la main de la police et si
j'étais pour être la main de la police
fallait que je sache exactement où
étaient les bons où étaient les méchants
et c'était très troubles
[Musique]
les tests de fait vendredi soir n'a dit
qu'il avait usage de drogues des
stéroïdes anabolisants
c'était une âme il on n'a pas idée la
répercussion qu'un test antidopage
positif pouvait avoir à l'époque c'était
d'un scandale de répercussion
internationale et qui a eu des
conséquences bénéfiques pour
l'antidopage tirs c'est un jour triste
pour le sport canadien pour le canada
pour le mouvement olympique et aussi
pour le sport en général on était envahi
par tout ce qu'il ya de télévision au
monde la journée ou au laboratoire a
testé un athlète d'élite et que cet
athlète d'élite saveur est positif c'est
une histoire qui va durer des mois
johnson qui a eu un manager qui prenait
au téléphone des heures pour me
convaincre de renverser notre test à la
testostérone de dire que c'était pas un
bon test pour permettre à johnson de
revenir pour une seule compétition
là c'en est venu carrément ou menacer
aussi à on pourrait vous donner de
l'argent
on pourrait vous donner de l'argent
suffisamment pour équiper les
laboratoires pour acheter ici pour
acheter ce dont vous proposer de
l'argent carrément oui
c'est james hansen 500 derniers mètres
et où le noir québec à 6,47 pour johnson
et sur une 6e 74
depuis que j'ai commencé à faire du
sprint j'entends des trucs c'est pas
juste des rumeurs des trucs bien fondé
et là tu dis oh my god
comment je vais faire pour y arriver
parce que tu sais comment ça fonctionne
bien sûr encore là ben johnson devrait
dominer ce plateau mais c'est que c'est
pas tout le monde qui intègre comme
madame ailleurs c'est ça aussi qui est
qui et la beauté de l'histoire qui
oblige à une qualité à 100% du temps
c'est que vous ne savez pas qui est le
positif qui est dans cette bouteille
après le test que vous avez fait vous
avez un code personne ne sait qui c'est
bien sûr que le deuxième test de ben
jonson j'avais une idée c'était le 60 m
qui s'était déroulé à montréal on sait
qu'ils prennent le champion de 2e c'est
lui ou brunes sur elle ces nuages gris
là qui étaient là
est-ce que lui aussi en prend c'était
frustrant mais c'est ça qui m'a coûté
c'est ça qui m'a coûté ma coûté cher
est ce que c'est une raison pour que moi
aussi j'veux dire que moi aussi je viens
d'apprendre ça jamais de la vie
jamais de la vie
[Musique]
j'étais la grande amie de cuba et de
l'antidopage kibet jusqu'à cette
histoire de sotomayor
javier sotomayor le prince des auteurs
déchu de sa dernière médaille d'or à
cause de la cocaïne
fidel castro qui à présent son organe de
médium locale pendant des jours il y
avait trois jours 3 heures et était
connu pour ses interventions fleuve des
heures et des heures sur le laboratorio
de montréal et puis toute la nôtre
ignominie tout simple je me disais c'est
quand même fort la politique ou la
rhétorique politique pour aller faire un
x sur une relation privilégiée depuis
dix ans avec le canada pour un athlète
qui était bien sûr l'image du pays le
jeu ben croire mais c'est de la
propagande alors qu'il savait très bien
que la cocaïne sotomayor s'était éteint
je suis innocent c'est tout ce que je
peux vous dire on nous accusait d'avoir
manipulé le test pour mettre la cocaïne
sous le la pression de l'enseigné
monsieur sotomayor nous le respectons
tous nous sommes tous convaincus qu'il
s'agit là d'un tissu de mensonges
on m'avait même demandé est-ce que vous
avez un désespoir cube est dans votre
laboratoire
une triste fin de carrière pour
geneviève jeanson à 24 ans la coureuse
cycliste vient d'être suspendu à vie
après un test positif à l epo geneviève
jeanson
ça a été dur oui ça a été dur parce que
c'est elle québec parce qu'elle était la
chérie des québécois j'ai encore
quelques emails quelques courriels de
gens qui étaient pas contents
[Musique]
ça a été un électrochoc qui apprend
firmes et les pierres d'autres qu'on
avait lance armstrong c'était une
entreprise quasi mafieuse et qui doutait
que lance armstrong était dopé ces
personnes c'était ce désir de convaincre
que la vérité gagne à la fin qui me
guidait
[Musique]
les indices sur un dopage russe étatisé
et systématique s'accumulaient c'était
le clash le pire qui pouvait avoir entre
la tête de grégory rodtchenko et la
mienne moi je carbure à la beauté du
test l'intégrité du test en ferme toutes
les portes lui les corruptions complète
cet homme c'est grigori en tchekhov
l'ancien directeur du laboratoire de
moossou je me souviens à 4 dans les
années 90 avoir envoyé des lettres au
cio pour dire écoutez au la boule moscou
il se passe n'importe quoi le gamin
parle de dopage comme si de rien n'était
[Musique]
mais je pense époque c'était à ce point
là et quand j'ai découvert ça sa mort
penne choqué et j'ai été j'ai été
vraiment chamboulé moi qui croyais avoir
du jugement je me suis dit pourtant ne
manquait jamais j'ai pensé qu'ils
pouvaient avoir eu les deux mains dans
un système aussi pourri et minable
ordinaire
[Musique]
le plein gens qui sont responsables
moi j'enlèverai jamais la responsabilité
première à l'athlète parce que c'est
l'individu c'est son corps et c'est le
devoir d'un individu de s'assurer de la
protection de la santé de son intégrité
c'est sûr qu'on abuse des athlètes c'est
un abus le dopage et c'est un abus qui
est table sur la vulnérabilité de cette
personne là que la conduite dopante
qu'on retrouve dans nos sociétés bien
sûr pour plein de raisons
refus de vieillir le refus de souffrir
l'atteinte des objectifs à tout prix
doit avoir une pilule pour ce lot et les
athlètes sont les fils et nos filles
il ya des tricheurs partout il ya des
gens pour arriver au top c'est par
n'importe quelle voix
en entrepreneuriat on a vu construction
on a vu d'autres domaines on voit
athlètes on voit mais comme société
aussi qu'est-ce qu'on encaisse on veut
les superstars on veut les performances
on veut des records la connaissance
scientifique c'est l'ouverture la
compréhension du monde est bien connu
que les stimulants des effets de graines
sont utilisées dans le sport et
l'intégrité
ça paye ça paye où on n'est pas obligé
de toujours reculer donc les chances que
c'était cela est été mal interprétés
sont plutôt faibles
il reste quoi faire pire est poursuivre
on ne peut rien réglé moi quand j'ai
commencé je mettais du bon ok les
athlètes le savez pop que doper c'était
triché et il s'est étonné qu'on leur met
une étiquette de tricheurs quand il
faisait ce qu'on leur demandait mais je
me suis dit bon maintenant les pendules
sont remises à l'heure donc dans dix ans
c'est réglé c'est pas réglé on peut pas
leur garantir qu'on va éradiquer
complètement le dopage c'est pas réglé
parce qu on nous manipule de la même
façon l'humain est pas devenu moins
vulnérables jour au lendemain ce qui est
triste c'est que les sportifs ont perdu
beaucoup de leur
statut de héros
[Musique]